People come from around the world to tour the Warner Bros. Studio in Burbank.
The four Warner brothers incorporated their film company in 1923.
They started making films on this lot in Burbank in 1928.
One of the most popular spots on the tour is the Central Perk set from Friends.
You just never know who you'll run into or what you'll see.
The lot is always changing.
It's never the same tour twice.
And that's what's fun and exciting for not only our guests, but for the tour guides also.
On the Warner Bros. Tour, you may get a chance to see the Batmobile,...
...the Lincoln from the Matrix,...
...the Mystery Machine from Scooby Doo,...
...and the Mach 5 from Speed Racer.
It's always something new, something fresh every time somebody comes in.
We have countless numbers of Batmobiles, cars, motorcycles. You name it, we have it.
This is just a small fraction of it.
The tour includes a visit to the Warner Bros. Museum.
It's the only museum in Hollywood on a studio lot.
Other studios, I guess, have tried every once in a while to do a museum...
...but Warner's is the only one who really has treasured their history.
The Harry Potter exhibit was amazing.
I really enjoyed the Friends set.
From hit TV shows to blockbuster films, the Warner Bros. Tour has it all.
For Time Warner SoCal News, I'm Ben McCain.